hey everybody welcome to the r studio
live stream uh we're going to be
covering a few different things today um
namely we're going to be going over a
lot of
our mark down here
from the from my home here in texas
so really excited to be here with
everybody today um i'm going to
get some questions from the chat we'll
do a little bit of live coding i've got
a slide deck
i hope you're gonna learn something with
me today and we're gonna have fun doing
this as an experiment um this is one of
my first times live streaming and first
time here on youtube live i've done a
little bit on on twitch
so excited to kind of learn along with
all of y'all as we go through this
experiment um let me know if you have
any questions and we'll try to answer
some of them in the chat and at the very
end we'll also upload the video to
youtube
one of my colleagues is going to be
answering questions in the chat as well
and sharing some links as long as we go
so let's get kicked off i'm going to
start sharing my screen
and we'll go from there
so let's do this one
all right so the first part we're going
to go through i'm going to have a slide
deck um you can find the slide deck if
you want to
um along with all the corresponding
materials at bit.ly
slash rmd marvel um i love this kind of
captain marvel movies or kind of built
the idea around some of that there's
just some little images and kind of uh
playing around with that idea
so the concept for today is we're gonna
go going higher further faster with
marvelous r markdown our markdown is
amazing it's one of my favorite r
packages one of my favorite data
products one of my favorite things for
just doing things in r and other
programming languages
i'll also be working inside our studio
primarily so you might see me log into
our studio here i want to be very clear
that everything i'm showing today up
until the very very end of the
presentation can be done in our studio
desktop or our studio server or our
studio workbench
so there's really not anything here
that's proprietary per se the vast
majority of this is open source our
markdown which is amazing you can be
very productive
in your school in your enterprise
as your hobby without really having to
go and buy anything
you do want to go a bit further with our
studio connect i'll talk about that at
the very end but that's a small
component today's presentation
so let me
go ahead and jump into the presentation
uh the kind of idea here again like i
mentioned with captain marvel is every
heroin story has kind of three core acts
and just like that we'll kind of go
through some of that today act one is
the story about our heroine is set up
act two some type of complication arises
that they have to face
and act three is the heroine finds
resolution defeats the bad guy you know
when wins the day
so for us we're gonna be talking about
the tool here's our markdown here's some
problems and here's some solutions you
can do with them basically some
workflows you can use to solve problems
with our markdown
the way i like to think about our
markdown is that it's a lot more than
just you know literate programming
although that's a huge component our
markdown as a taxonomy can do many
different things it can be an
environment where you're writing code
and writing text and creating graphics
and creating statistical models or data
science or machine learning but it can
also just be an end result as a data
product you can create something like
this slide deck i'm presenting which was
made with our markdown you can use it as
a control document to kind of control
your code flow and how you organize your
projects and bring different snippets of
code together and lastly you can also
use it for templating so basically
leveling up your skills and
taking one thing and turning it into a
hundred or taking one example and
adjusting it and recreating it without
having to rewrite all the code
so we'll be going into all four of those
different taxonomies today
the first one and i think the obviously
one of the core workflows that you're
going to do in our markdown
is literate programming
the goal here is that you're going to
capture your code text or comments and
your output in a single document so you
have essentially like this reproducible
workflow of capturing your code along
with the output along with any kind of
comments about what the code is doing or
the outputs that you're seeing all
together so you can share one document
or one report with someone if you want
to do that but you can also reproduce it
because you have the source code
the idea of literate programming has
been around for
a long time donald knuth has this nice
quote about
literate programming as a programming
paradigm
and the explanation of it is that it's
logic in a natural language such as
english
interspersed with snippets of macros and
traditional source code from which the
compilable source code can be generated
now when we think about source code in r
we have code chunks so you have these
little portions here where you might
recognize some of these you know your
favorite gg plot some d plier to filter
a data set but then with our markdown
you can also intersperse actual text you
know write about it just as you would in
a word word processor but now you get
the benefit of doing code and text
together
the other component i just want to bring
up here is that there is the yaml header
which allows you to define certain
metadata so up here at the top you can
say i want my output to be an html
document so this will when it's rendered
when you finish it and you click render
it will actually create an html
object that you can open up in a web
browser and you could switch this out to
do schrenden or any other type of things
or a presentation like i'm doing today
now going a step further beyond just
that plain text visual our markdown was
introduced in rstudio 1.4 so this has
been around for six or seven months but
there's still lots of people who may not
have heard about it so i wanted to cover
it today
you can essentially think of this as not
only do you have the ability to look at
the source code and the you know raw
markdown you can also view it in a way
where it shows you the actual rendered
outputs
so when you create a table it shows you
a table when you include a graphic it
shows you the graphic you don't just
have to believe that okay this code
should bring in this image we'll
actually do that live inside our studio
in addition to that it you know can do
things with latex or with spell type
real-time spell checking or
all the different source code that you
still want to be using and you get a
nice header up here that allows you to
add things like bold italics
cross throughs bullet points tables all
of those things with insertion
but it still allows you to do that with
code and it actually adds the code into
it
i'll be walking through this in a second
here live so this may seem like oh this
is really cool but we'll see it here in
a second
and then the last part is that our
markdown in literature programming is
not just for r
you can do things like include python
via reticulate you can use sql inside
code chunks to actually write raw sql
code you can include css or javascript
for some of your front-end development
work and you can include other things
for bash rcpp stan and a lot of other
different languages
so altogether neter provides kind of
interfaces to 52 possible languages so
you can do a lot in our markdown even
though a lot of what i'll be showing
today will be focus on r
so with that let's hop over into our
studio
i'm working inside the rstudio team
evaluation again this is not necessary
it's just a reproducible environment i
can use
so i'm actually logged into an rstudio
workbench session
this might look a bit different
initially from what you're used to i'm
using rstudio on say your desktop but
the workflows are essentially identical
once i log into our studio i can hop
into there and open up some stuff i was
working on over the past you know few
days and week
and we can go into some live coding of
literate programming
i'm going to be bouncing back and forth
between
the kind of source document editing that
i'm doing here in the live coding and
back to the presentation so stick with
me ask questions if they come up and i
look forward to kind of learning with
you as we go along
so there's a lot going on in here so i'm
going to close down some
some objects but in reality we're just
inside the rstudio environment
so again this will work just the same on
our studio desktop as you would inside r
studio workbench or server pro or server
the first one i'll be doing is the
visual editor so if you again want to go
to bit.ly slash rmb marvel you can
actually open up the same files i'm
working on
the first one i'm going to use is this
visual rmd
file
so this file will look pretty similar to
any our markdown document you've seen
before there's a yaml header there's
some code chunks there's a bunch of text
there's a table here there's some images
all sorts of things going on
if i want to switch over into visual
editor mode i can click on the visual
editor button right here
so this button will switch me to the
visual markdown editor
once i click that it'll reload the
screen and it will then convert what i'm
seeing on the page into the actual
represented output so now rather than
you know three pound signs and intro it
actually creates a level three header
all of my links get turned into
hyperlinks my code chunks get a gray
background and i can still you know
execute them i can still run tidy verse
and load the palmer penguins library
but i don't have kind of all the
raw text around it
it will load tables and i can adjust the
size of those tables so we can resize
this table real quick
we can
move this over so now we have a nice
table so that large represented table
that i have here with embedded
hyperlinks is now a visual table
and it's got some included graphics
basically it's just walking you through
how to use visual or markdown and
there's a lot of cool things you can do
with visual or markdown
what might be more useful is like
jumping into an actual code example as
opposed to kind of a demo of what visual
markdown does
so if we go to
the penguins folder
we've got a couple different documents
in here i'm going to start with the ping
and report detail
and again i'm back into the plain text
version so you can see it still has
loaded some of the graphics there's some
initial exploration here what i want to
do is walk through this as a kind of
literate program example
so we're going to move into visual
markdown mode so again i'll click the
visual markdown button
and now we have the
formatted text along with my code chunks
we're gonna use a couple libraries so
i'm gonna load uh tidyverse palmer
penguins broom skimar and the bootstrap
lib package
i've got a couple different documents
here talking about what literate
programming is
some initial exploration that we've used
for
you how to use skimmer some examples of
inline code chunks and we're going to do
is do a quick skim of these data
so if you're not familiar with the
plumber penguins data set it's basically
a relatively small data set about 344
rows and it includes three different
species of penguins for both male and
female
this is a nice alternative to say the
iris dataset so you can use it to
replace some of that in your workflows
and skimar is just showing us what are
the different variables in this so
there's a lot of information about the
bill length basically how long their
beak is
as well as the build depth how how broad
it is
and then their flipper length or how
long their arms are their body weight
their body mass in the year that this
was observed all the data was collected
in 2008 and uh big thanks to allison
horson and allison hill for putting
together this data set into a nice art
package with a wonderful website
so now with basically you know three or
four lines of code is able to get all
this metadata about the uh about this
data set so there's there's a little bit
of missing data the average grouped by
species and build length and all the
different variables the standard
deviation and a histogram of what that
data set looks like
now you might be saying why didn't i
just use dplyr and you can still do that
so i'm inside in the visual editor i can
say okay we're also going to look at
some specific statistics we'll split the
groups by species and look at which ones
are the lightest and which ones have the
shortest slippers oh looks like i made a
mistake and uh our studio is catching
that i misspelled lightest so i will
correct that thank you for the warning
there
and now i'll run this code chunk and
we'll now get our d plier output so
we've grouped by species and sex we've
summarized got the weight of the animals
the flipper length of the animals and
we've arranged by descending weight
so what we observe here is that the
adelaide penguins look to be
the lightest although there is some n
a's in the sex so some of the missing
data there is in the sex column
and the males are about equivalent to
the chinstrap males but the females are
much lighter than the rest of the other
ones
okay so it looks like the adoleigh or
the lightest penguin i can continue
going into my code
and i can filter out the is in a's
and
i can find some that actually have this
if i want to make it where there aren't
any n a's in the sex i can also just
change that to a
kind of eliminate the exclamation point
here does the opposite so it does finds
no nas in the data set
so we've only got about 11 rows of the
340-ish that are missing data
but let's go ahead and make sure that
we're not missing any animals that are
missing body weight so we'll find the
smaller data set
so i'll kind of go through this and
really the idea here is that we've got a
lot of text we've got inner snippets of
code we've got graphics that are going
to show up in line
and we can create even fancier graphics
or split it out by specific portions
nice graphics here
and then we can find a small linear
model between the body mass and the
flipper length there's a very strong
linear relationship between how big the
animal is and how long its flippers are
this might seem silly we're kind of
sticking to
a fun data set because i don't want us
to worry too much about what the data is
as opposed to the techniques we're using
really what we've done here for a few
minutes is just walk through a live
coding example and it's really just me
running code but you can see that you
know when if i gave this to a colleague
or i was looking at this this is nice to
read through like this reads almost like
a report already even though i'm able to
edit it and kind of change things as i
go
so you get this experience of kind of a
word editor or a word processor
with the ability to run that code and
that's really what the beauty of
literate programming is is mixing in the
comments or the things you're writing
along with the code you're writing
the other part i want to
show if we go back to the visual editor
is we can also do this same workflow
with reticulate i can actually use some
python
so i'm going to again switch to visual
editor mode
and just show you that it does still
work for for python and nr
so we'll load uh these libraries i've
loaded reticulate
to allow me to use python on the back
end and then i can import pandas
and uh get the penguins data set into
the pandas object now
if i look at the environment i have the
ability to switch between r and python
and see those different objects
i'm in the python environment now and i
can see the data set that i brought in
so you can see the same one you'll
notice that python refers to nas or
missing data is nan
versus r is going to refer to
those as n a's
so small difference but it does
translate back and forth nicely
so let's close that down
and then uh since i kind of showed you
the workflow of doing this live like
let's just knit the document
so we'll take the uh reticulate document
i have that has a little bit of python
it does some some data cleaning uh in
pandas as opposed to dplyr and we can
show the the final output here in the
browser
so this is very important penguin
analysis that we're doing here
so we'll again we're pulling in pandas
instead of skim r we're using the
describe
function from pandas and we're looking
at a few different things by the species
this is done in python and then we'll do
some group by summaries with pandas
again so again grouping by species and
sex getting some outputs
and then showing the data set when we
drop some nas and filter to just species
equal to ally
we can then take that python object and
pipe it back into ggplot i'm much more
comfortable in ggplot than i am in
matplotlib or other libraries in python
so i just moved it back in
but really just the idea of like if you
know a little bit of r know a little bit
of python you can work with them in the
same document and kind of use that for
learning or use it for some of the
reporting or other kind of scientific
computing that you're doing
cool so we spent quite a bit of time on
literate programming we're going to go
back into the presentation and talk
about our next taxonomy also take a
breath and look at some of the questions
that are coming in
um has question number one was has
anyone found a good method of real-time
collaboration on our markdown in a
similar way as google docs that's a
great question um obviously you could do
something that's more asynchronous by
checking into something like version
control
so just as i was saying with
using the code
rmd marvel
if you go to say like github you can
literally use the things that i'm
working on and
edit those so i was just in the visual
editor and then the one i was working on
was the reticulate
dash dock so now you could add some
edits to this you could pull it in and
work on it that would be asynchronous
an alternative would be that rstudio
workbench actually allows you to do live
editing the same document with project
sharing so that is a professional
product that we offer um but that is an
option if you're worried about like
collaborating at work and needing to
work remotely but still shared documents
you could also just have a shared drive
like if you're talking about google you
can upload documents edit them and move
them back and forth i still think that
version control was probably the best
idea for
just like being able to comment on
something
make edits and then try and talk through
that process
um one other thing how do you have that
many pains let's talk about
go back into this for a second
um so our studio 1.4 introduced not only
the visual editor which again is this
button that allows you to show the kind
of rendered output and also add a
support for
the
multi-multi-panes
so if i go to tools
and go to global.are global options
pane layout
i can add new source columns so you can
see i have my four typical panes but
then i have an additional source column
and if i apply this and click ok
go back in here
and drag this over
i now have the ability to work on a
single document in the middle and also
have a more basic report off to the side
so i can edit like two files at the same
time you're not editing the same file
but two different files i use this quite
a bit for doing things like shiny where
you might be writing essentially like
the front end portion the user interface
and the backend server component in
separate files and bringing them both in
together so that's a good option
but uh let's hop back into
the presentation real quick
so we talked about literary programming
for a while uh the next kind of taxonomy
of using our markdown is the idea of a
data product and here we're using our
markdown to
in using r to generate a final output
for consumption so yes you know you want
to be reproducible yes you want to
include code but here you're mostly
concerned with i want to create
something that i'm going to give to
someone to help them make a decision
convince them or just report on
something like here here's the daily
report or here's a machine learning
pipeline i ran with tidy models and fit
all these different parameters did hyper
perimeter tuning and here's the final
model and it's fit but with all of the
code available
there's a ton of different data products
you can create with our markdown you can
create reports um so static html reports
like i was just showing when we rendered
that document
pdfs you can save out so they could you
know share them via email or just have
something you can have offline
rich text formats github documents or
even word documents
um presentations just like this one is
this one was created in uh schrengen so
that is a our markdown package using
reveal.js
or remark.js i'm sorry
you can create powerpoint presentations
you can create other kind of more native
reveal.js presentations beamer for latex
you can create full-blown dashboards
with flex dashboard that can be either
static or you can integrate shiny and
make them interactive
entire websites so some of you all may
actually have our markdown blogs i
personally use distill for my personal
blog and blog down is a great option for
a lot of power and uses hugo on the back
end to convert markdown and our mark
down into complex sophisticated websites
you can write books beautiful books that
you know people have literally published
you think of like r for data science the
book by hadley wickham and garrett
grolman
that was written with book down and you
can actually look at it online in the
book down format
and lastly one of the things i'm really
excited about for our markdown and data
products are html widgets you may have
been exposed to dt or the javascript
data table library or reactable which is
similar and creates interactive
tables
in r that use javascript on the back end
so without even having to use shiny or
server you can have the ability to sort
rearrange or change the data you're
seeing on screen
all at once
there's plot leaf or graphics crosstalk
for interaction we'll dive into a little
bit of that
so we're going to hop back into the
environment here so we'll go back into
my penguin project
i'm again going to push this
extra pane over because i want to zoom
in a little bit more on this one
and we're going to go into penguin
project
and look at data products
so the first one we're going to be
looking at is i was talking about
different output formats um so distill
being the ability to like create a web
page in uh
in our so let's close down some of these
we'll save that
clean up my environment a little bit i
got a lot going on here y'all
so close this one close the readme close
down some whiskers the multiplied we've
got a lot of exciting things today and i
don't want to get to them too fast so
we're going to close down all of these
and then i'm going to pull this one over
this has my penguin distill which again
is penguin dash distill and o2 data
products
this may look almost the same as what
you were looking at before with your
visual or markdown it's essentially the
same report or similar
but when i knit it or render it that's
when it gets turned into the new format
so with the visual markdown editor you
still get all this nice formatting but
when i actually click knit and actually
ask r in our markdown to to render it
into the new format
it will render it out as something else
so in this case because i have it set as
distill
so you can see output distilled dash
disarm
sorry distill
colon colon distill article it's going
to create an actual distill article
instead of a basic html doc
so here's penguin's distilled this looks
quite a bit different i love that it has
this floating table of contents that has
some information about when it was
published who the author is it's more of
like scientific writing native to web so
this is an html document but it is
really
like how to do scientific writing
and again you still get all the niceties
and kind of the core our markdown work
so this is still the same
code i was using but i was able to
generate a different output um simply by
changing the r mark down the ammo so
still a lot of the great things but it's
got really really nice like uh headers
where i can like
grab this you know specific link to the
modeling section and share that link
or i can look at my different models
that i've chosen at the bottom and where
there are squares at the very bottom
here i can do the wrap up
and it gives me this nice table of
contents where i can jump back and forth
between everything
so i really like the still that's a good
option if you're trying to create
a um a personal website or some
scientific articles
so let's get back into here
i'm going to
click on this drag this one all the way
over
and the next one we're going to do is a
shirengan
presentation
so again the data product here is um
more
of a presentation so just like the
presentation i'm showing you this one
was created with our markdown i
literally wrote a bunch of our markdown
code to generate the presentation that
we're going through
this looks pretty similar to what i was
doing before in terms of it's got really
the same code chunks the specialness
here is that instead to kind of tell
this presentation format this is a new
slide i use three dashes to say go to
the next slide
go to the next slide for each of these
different sections so each one is a
slide break but i can still use all of
the essentially the same code i was
using
now this really makes more sense when
again i render it out so if i knit this
document or render the r markdown into a
shrinking presentation
i can then open that document and give
me one second to pull it over
and then now we have that same kind of
report i was talking about as a live
presentation in a few seconds
so here's the information we're looking
at is here's some penguins we're looking
at their bill length their build depth
their body mass their flipper length all
these fun little data points
we're talking about literary programming
here are the specific statistics i'm
interested in so grouping the data by
species and sex and getting their body
weight and their flipper length
i can clean up the data
there was some n a's and we dropped all
those with naomi
and now let's get into the plotting
section so we're going to show a quick
distribution of the data we'll have the
example of the live code up here and
then we'll show a linear model and a
scatter plot this is again the same gdp
plot that i had before i didn't have to
adjust anything
and then we'll move on to the modeling
section so now we have all of our models
i'm fitting i've got a list objects of
some different formulas and then we're
going to summarize those into different
models
broom to clean them up and now i have a
nice table with the gt package of what
are my different model formulas i was
using so looking at flipper length by
body mass the r squared the p values the
sigma the statistics about these
so obviously i'm flying through this
portion but the idea here is that um
with literally like no change to the
underlying code i'm able to get
all of the different things into this
object so like get them into a
presentation
um
yeah there's one more example i'm going
to go through about
data products
and then we're going to talk a little
bit more in the presentation
so
number one a flex dashboard
is a way to create dashboards in r
what i can do is actually run this
document
i'm running the document because it has
a shiny run time
shiny is not required for flex dashboard
but does give it a lot of extra power in
terms of now you can have a server
component on the back end and execute
something
so the basic idea of this um flex
dashboard is it separates different
components into portions so i have kind
of a tab here for miles per gallon
weight a tab here for miles per gallon
cylinders and then a table about them
what shiny is doing is giving me linked
brushing or the ability to select
specific
objects or observations
and then show something different so by
using this as a control environment i'm
able to just limit it to
specific
miles per gallon a specific weight
combination or even just one data point
or i can get a whole section and zoom in
on those and then adjust both the the
table and the graphics here
this is done with shiny and it's taken
literally verbatim from the flex
dashboard site so you can actually
recreate this or the source code that
they share is embedded inside of it
the shiny runtime might you know that's
very exciting but that does require you
to manage a uh shiny server or rstudio
connect on the backend
so an alternative because you're working
on our markdown is something like
crosstalk and what crosstalk does is
gives you the ability to cross
communicate or cross talk between
different html widgets
an html widget might be a plotly graphic
or a dt data table or a reactable table
or of all sorts of different html
widgets the idea is that those are using
javascript they're writing via r
and they can still communicate with each
other
so
there was a question in the chat does
knit mean render essentially an
inter-based function
what knit or render means is take the
document run it from the top to the
bottom in a linear fashion and create
the output format
there's all sorts of side effects that
are good in terms of you could write out
different files the videos render is
like run the entire document and render
the output or knit the document and
render the output those are
interchangeable you can use the rstudio
mip button or if you're doing it from
the r console you could do our markdown
uh
render
and just pass the file name to it so
it's not required to use inside our
studio but we do provide a net button
for it
so with that let's let's knit the
document real quick
and we will uh wait for it to render so
it's going to go through and reading the
lines and pulling in the code
and it's going to generate an output for
us to walk through while that's
rendering i'm going to look at some of
the questions in the chat
um
there's a great question about jobs
the jobs pain that i want to talk to in
a second um
okay and this one was output to
reactable so let's do that in a web
browser
that's not the one that's exciting
though uh let's do crosstalk html so the
output that we created was a crosstalk
document
again this might look like the exact
same plot we've been creating for a
little bit while or for a little while
flipper length and body mass so there's
a linear relationship between that
but the beauty here is that with
crosstalk i have an interactive graphic
in terms of um
this here all these little points i'm
hovering over the hover text is comes in
for free like you you get the hover text
and all these different documents
with the table you have the ability to
go paginated or sort by species sort by
sex sort by any column
so you have interactive components
interactive graphics interactive tables
all of this available for free and all
of us able to be used within your
enterprise within your hobby within your
workspace
what crosstalk is doing is giving you
some of these filters so this may look
exactly like shiny
but there is no shiny server on the back
end this is all done in the browser on
your local machine
so i can filter this data set to only
show female penguins so now the only sex
in the table is female and all the
observations we're seeing up here are
female only
i can show just the males and do the
same thing i can show the males and the
females together great
i can filter the body mass to show only
the lightest penguins and we can kind of
see the drop off of the gentoo
as we get to about 4 000
grams
there's not really any gen 2 penguins
that we observe at that body weight
so again all of this is happening where
i'm changing things here it's affecting
the plotly graphic it's affecting the
table and they're communicating together
to give you this output
um and again
the beauty of
our markdown and the beauty of crosstalk
and this javascript libraries is you
don't have to manage a server you could
literally publish this to github or
netlify or our studio connect or just
take the file and literally like deliver
it to someone else by like email if you
wanted to or by shared drive they could
open it and get this interactivity that
you're expecting
so all this amazing things you can do
with crosstalk and r markdown you can
still leverage shiny on top of that
if you wanted to to get even more power
or to actually execute new r code you
are limited to what these libraries can
do in javascript but if you add shiny
then anything you can do in r can be
added into the object as well
so back into here there was a great
question in the chat about the jobs
panel and part of the idea is that
could you execute our markdown renders
as a background job
the jobs panel might be new to a lot of
folks
this is again available in the rstudio
desktop the local ide it's a free thing
it's just available
you could render anything
or markdown if you wanted to as a
background job you would just have an r
script that literally contained like our
markdown render
and then whatever the markdown document
you wanted to do so you could
parallelize some work if you wanted to
like you know render this one i know
it's going to take a while also render
this one and then that leaves you free
to continue using the r console to do
other things so these jobs are still
executed in your local environment but
behind the scenes so they don't
you know use the same r uh source that
you're using you do them as a background
or an alternative um
or
our environment
um so yeah so the jobs panel is amazing
that was also introduced relatively
recently
you can use it what i use it up for a
lot is for long-running computation like
parameter tuning or grid search where
you're going through a lot of different
things all at once it could take 30
minutes or 45 minutes or even longer in
some cases i don't want to
lose everything
like lose the ability to do my console
for 30 minutes
so when i was watching sliced i was
really hoping
a lot of people are going to be using
background jobs so they can continue
like doing
graphics in the r console while the code
is fitting in the back end that would be
a cool example
um let's hop back into the presentation
we talked about quite a few of these
different data products we've got about
25 30 minutes left so i want to make
sure that we get through everything
um for the
table column width um the basic idea for
the visual editor is when you you know
bring in a table or create a table it
has default widths those will adjust to
the size of the contents there are some
cases where if you have like really
really long content it can create a
table that you need to adjust and you
can just drag it over
with your mouse to adjust the size of
the column
for shrinking and all the colors and
layout styles i highly recommend the
shrendigan femur package by derrick
aidan bui that is an amazing package
that allows you to write full themes for
shrinking and you can get you know
beautiful colors and specific um
you know fonts or css embedded in there
as well to make it custom
for gt summary tables and our markdown
um i use gt all the time inside our
markdown i don't think there's any known
issues with gt summary um but the idea
would be is that if you use gt summary
within our markdown you can just render
it out and get the gt summary in there
as well
a great question here are all these
features are showing in our studio free
yes everything i'm talking about right
now is free these are open source
packages some of them are community
based some of them are studio based this
is the beauty of open source and our
community and the javascript community
and the python community is that all
these different components can be
connected together kind of you know
revamped or integrated and you get this
amazing power within free and open
source tools
um last question i'll answer here is
you could use different yaml so you
could uh like render one as a shrinking
one as a distill the one difference is
that shrinking has a very different
internal syntax those three dashes are
going to create new slides in schrengen
but they will create a horizontal line
and distiller on markdown so while you
could have one document literally
generate
two or five different types of output
you may have to change some of the
skeleton of it not the code but the
skeleton of like how it presents
and the last one here when you do render
when the document is a flex dashboard
you just render it just as you would
with anything else the difference is if
you are using shiny you're actually
going to run the document it essentially
treats it as pre-rendered so it renders
the flex dashboard then brings in the
shiny component if you don't have shiny
there and you're just doing static or um
html widgets like crosstalk and flex
dashboard then you can just render it
like anything else
so
we've talked quite a bit about all that
thank you for kind of sticking with me
through a quick run through a bunch of
data products
the next taxonomy i'd like to cover is
the idea of a control document so this
is
kind of a step beyond the classical ones
the first two people have probably done
a lot of that control documents are some
that i had not done as much of before
i'd done some research so the goal here
is to modularize your data science tasks
and use our markdown to control your
code flow
that seems kind of clinical in terms of
like code flow data science tasks like
what are we talking about here
part of what we're talking about here is
you know taking something and generating
something new with it so parameters in
our markdown can be added to the yaml
header with the params colon and then
whatever you want the object to be named
so in this case like species equal to
adoles
when i render this document it will run
the code in here but then it will pull
in whatever the parameter is so without
changing the body code i can change what
the actual report does
so i can say for the adelaide penguins
generate this uh you know these
different filters in this different
graphic
and i can just change this one line of
code in terms of this parameter and it
will generate an entirely new report or
entirely new document that is specific
to that
you can have multiple parameters i'm
just showing the bare bones example of
one
parameter with one
component you could have five or six
different parameters or more and you
could have multiple different things
within that parameter so you could have
like a string or a vector inside there
and kind of run through all the
different ones
the idea is that you're just without
having to change all the code and
rewrite 10 different reports you could
generate 10 reports just by changing the
parameter 10 times so very powerful
you can also reference our files so for
a lot of folks you're like ah you know
like our markdown it feels like a lot of
you know there's a lot of different
power there but you know i have to write
all these different things i'm just
going to stop in a dot r file
um you can use and reference external.r
files a couple of different ways so you
can always just source an internal r
file and just read in things from an
external file
but the nidar read chunk option kind of
gives you the best of both worlds
here you might see that i have code
chunks that are named in terms of this
is smaller penguins and this is plot
penguins
but
none of there's no code in there
there's nothing in here and that's
because with read chunk i'm actually
able to read in from a dot r file
specific chunks
so this
colon call or sorry
pound sign pound sign and four dashes
essentially creates a chunk label
so even though i'm inside dot r files
our markdown can understand this
descriptor and say okay everything
inside here is the smaller penguins
chunk everything inside here is the plot
dash penguins chunk so i can actually
write things in a dot our file reference
them in multiple different dot r
markdowns you can imagine i have a
sharingan i have pdf i have word doc and
html all of those could reference dot
our files so that you're just writing
the components in our markdown that are
specific to our markdown like how to
create the presentation and you can
source some of the other more complex
code you're writing an r
from the daughter of file
just an option not mandatory but
definitely possible
the other idea is child documents so i
could have a core kind of parent
document here that is just an html
document
it's got a couple library calls in terms
of loading tidy version palmer penguins
and then just like before with the read
chunk i have a blank
uh blank chunk here there's no code in
it
but it's saying for this chunk read in
the child report adelaide report dot our
markdown
and that will take everything in this so
the you know smaller this code chunk
this text this code chunk and embed it
into this portion so essentially you
wrote all this and put it into the
parent document
again the idea of like you're able to
build up different components and reuse
parts from different documents into kind
of a parent or a core
document that you want to reference that
in
so again if you're playing around with
different output formats you could
always just you know write a document
and change the output format but
sometimes you may want to actually
leverage a specific report that gets
brought in
this becomes even more powerful if you
think of like conditionally adding a
report
so for my example it's the same report
that we had before so we're bringing in
this child report
the parent report now has a conditional
statement essentially
if this object is chinstrap
or if it's adoleigh then bring in this
report
so that will basically say as long as
this means chen strap or this means
adoleigh then render the adalat report
and bring it in
the better example and the kind of more
complex example is if a criteria is
matched so if uh values are above or
below a certain value that is concerning
then bring in all this other code
run it and generate the kind of
worrisome report there that you want to
catch up to like um
the you know the data is way off from
what the norm is oh my gosh what's going
on add all this different thing to check
the data quality that you don't
necessarily aren't doing all the time
but you're doing it for here
that being said please check your data
and check data quality but just as an
example you can do these kind of if else
or conditional statements inside the
child document
another idea of like
parent and child documents is blastula
blastula can be used with things like
gmail or you can use it with our studio
connect to send emails
the core idea and there's a bit more
code here we're loading some libraries
we're creating some graphics and then we
have this render email portion it will
basically take a blastula written email
so you can see that this penguin email
the output is blastula blaster email
and render that as an html email and
then send it the example i'm using here
is rendering it and sending it via our
studio connect you can also render it
via smtp which is a protocol that like
gmail uses so again connect is not
required to do this it's a nice
integration but you can do this for free
with your smtp style servers
these emails can intrude arbitrary r
output like ggplot or even you know
tables or images of tables you can
basically include a lot of different
things inside an email that you're
sending out to your colleagues
or to yourself i use these a lot for
do this thing and then tell me what the
output is in a summary
so
we covered those and
most of those kind of
in my mind
the code is covered here in terms of all
we're doing is pulling in code and
rendering it so i'm not going to go
through the live examples i did include
an entire section inside the penguin
project
so control documents has blaster emails
it has emailers programs external files
using child using conditional child
you're welcome to walk through those
again at bitly
r d marvel
but because it's just rendering the same
document over and over i'm going to
spend the next 10 or 15 minutes talking
about our next topic which is going to
be templating i really love the idea of
templating as well
so for templating a lot of people think
of like
taking one thing and making it other
things or taking one thing and changing
something about it to make it different
so here captain marvel is working with
her friend's child and changing the look
of her outfit so that's really cool and
you could change you know what an our
markdown appearance looks like with a
different theme or different css
but more of what we're talking about is
don't repeat yourself generate input
templates or output documents from
code so if you think about parameters
that's something we used before was you
know defining a parameter setting it as
a species equal to adoleigh
and then we generate this report
obviously you could go into the r
markdown delete this type out you know
chin strap or gen 2 or one of the other
species and click render or you could do
it from the command line or the r
console
so with our markdown render you can take
this report so the penguin.org markdown
and define the parameter as something
else so here a list of species equals
the gen2 instead of adoleigh and now
this will generate that report
with code with that new parameter so now
you've generated two reports
with
the same report essentially so two
different outputs from the same input so
that's very powerful
a more interesting example in my mind is
multi-renders where you actually take
all the different possibilities of the
parameter and generate all of them
so here i'm wrapping our markdown render
into my own render function so that i
pass in penguin my render function
it takes the same report
it replaces the species with whatever
the ping when i put in
and then it creates an output file with
the name of that penguin dash report
html
so now i can find all the distinct
penguin species i can pull that column
out and then i can render that with per
lock so basically goes through each of
the different possibilities and
generates a new report for all of those
so now i have an analog report a chin
strap and a gen 2 report all from one
set of starting code
you can imagine that this could be
something like i'm changing the year or
changing the month or changing the day
to generate this report data or for like
a modeling task i'm changing hyper
parameters or the different modeling
function or a different data set and
generating an entire report on it so you
can do a lot of different things with
parameters and looping through different
parameters
now the other ideas rather than
generating 10 reports out you might want
to generate
multiple things in one report
so here i'm doing something similar i'm
uh but all within one report
so i'm sourcing an external uh file this
is multi-plot which is an r function
that basically outputs markdown text it
outputs a plot and prints it and then i
add some blank spacing
and then i have a loop here so this is a
code chunk called loop output i'm using
results as is so it just pastes the
literal output here of what this r code
generates so it actually output
essentially text
i'll take the penguins data set find the
distinct species pull the species and
then walk through again with per um this
function three times
what that does is generates three
different versions of the same text
in the same graphic but
nuanced or kind of specific to whatever
the input was whatever the penguin that
we're generating was
so let's uh walk through that one real
quick so we're in templating i'm going
to show a couple things so
penguin params
i'm going to pull this over
again the species is adoleigh so i can
knit this document
pardon me
let's let that document render or knit
and then i'm going to pull it into the
browser
so this is a pretty bare bones report
but you can see 193 are classified as
adelaide the distribution of adelaide
penguins are below and there's a big
chunk of them that are out of line
we go in here and change this to chin
strap
chin strap i can again knit that report
and get the essentially new one out so
if i refresh this it should be chin
strap i think
let's see
yep there's chin strap chin strap and
now we have 276 penguins instead of 344.
so i can do it that way i can do it with
knit with parameters so if you just
click up here on knit and go down to
knit with parameters
it will pull up
like a kind of shiny component where i
can change this and do
gen 2 so now we can knit that to gen 2.
so it's going to do the same thing and
render
a new report for me with gen 2. so
here's the report we're looking at
uh pull it over there
so that's possible um
a couple different options you can knit
and just change it you can knit with
parameters
but the more powerful part that i like
is the
the multi-plot or render all
so render all is the idea of like rather
than manually changing things or going
through all the different options i can
again use my render function
if i go up here and get all those
my
render function
here we go
so this will render the specific
documents but i want to render all of
them together again this is the same
thing i showed in the presentation of
here's the templates the penguin params
and then we're going to show
the species equal chin strap that's fine
with the penguin names we're going to
pull those out
what this basically gives us is the
three different penguin names
and then we're going to walk through
those with the uh
per walk render function to just prove
to you that that actually happened
i got some code here to show you that
this was run at uh 352
whatever the time is on the server on
august 26th and it happened about a
second later
was when they were actually generated so
these reports were generated just now
and it gave us the out of my report the
chin strap report in the gym tube report
so that's super powerful and i think
that's a really really cool idea
the
loop within a dock are markdown
is also
really really fun
so here this is the one that's using the
um
[Music]
reports up here in terms of it's going
to walk through that multi-plot that
i've already defined and it's going to
create three different outputs in the
same document so let's knit that and see
what it looks like
when we render this it's actually
reporting out as is
and then it's going to generate this
loop within the doc
html let's take a look at it so for
adelaide it gives you a level three
header and it gives you um
these observations so here's 151
observations of adelaide penguins and
the flipper length is 190.
for gen 2 it's got a different graphic
and different numbers and then for chin
strap a different graphic and different
numbers
so from one dot our file you're able to
generate multiple outputs within a
single document so again a slightly
different idea
the last idea i'll talk about is whisker
versus glue so uh the way i like to
think about this is one versus two if
you're thinking about these uh these
parameters on the outside of these
brackets
glue is logic templating in terms of you
can take a string
put anything you want with valid r code
inside these brackets and it will
interpret that and execute it inside
that context so very very cool very
strong package
whisker is logic list templating meaning
you have to define the object at a time
and then pull it in it also uses two
brackets instead of one
the reason why it's logic list is that
it's really thinking of it just as text
as opposed to code up here so if you try
to do the same
number of row of empty cars it will just
print a blank there because it can't
interpret that so it just returns blank
um where whisker is very powerful is the
idea of generating actual r d or dot md
files like basically
generating new input files or text files
from an input file
that kind of blew my mind the first time
i thought about it so let's walk through
an example real quick
if i have this report so this is an
actual our markdown document
but you can see i've got these double
brackets in a few different places so
the name of the penguin the name of the
species
and some long pros here
now you could think well i could just
replace this with params but the beauty
is is when you use whisker to fill in
this document which you see on the right
so adelaide penguin adoly
and then this long prose about them
it will actually um
allow you to still work with the
document it's still a raw dot rmd file
so that's really powerful and you can
continue working with it
so this is what that function looks like
that i was using use penguin template
which reads in this file
fills it with whisker basically like
replaces all of the different
observations with double brackets with
species equal adelaide and this long
prose and generates that output
so
let's show that really quick um whisker
versus glue
uh sorry let's do
[Music]
my whiskers use penguin template all
right
so here we're going to define that
function
species
long pros and we're going to use this
use penguin template we've now filled
the blank template with this really long
text string and a bunch of other stuff
and now we can actually navigate and
edit that file
inside our studio
so now we have an our markdown document
that i can continue adding to
here is more text
but i've programmatically filled it with
different parameters of interest
so there's certain times where this is
amazingly powerful there's certain times
where you should probably just use
params but the idea of like if you want
to be able to continue editing it like
if you're generating a shrinking
document and putting all this code and
filling some parameters but then
continue editing the slides this could
be a really powerful option
um so we've talked about all the
different things you can do inside
templating the last component here and
we've only got a couple minutes i think
that was part of the intention is that
all the things i've showed up to this
point have literally been all the
amazing things you can do with our
markdown for free and within your own
kind of choices this last component is a
bit about our markdown within our studio
connect
so our studio connect is a professional
product from our studio
um it's a hosting and execution platform
for shiny our markdown plumber as well
as things like jupiter flask dash and
streamlight for our python folks
you can use it to execute or schedule
our markdown for basically anything so
not only can you host things there but
you can actually have connect re-render
or re-execute this code in the future so
you could provide parameterize our
markdown where someone can actually go
through
change parameters and re-render it
without having to know anything about r
you could schedule etl jobs and pull
from sql with dbplier apis with hater or
spark with sparkly r and then bring
those into r and do other things with
them
connect provides reports that actually
have logging and history so you can have
multiple versions of the same report
over time
you can schedule some of your
long-running training steps that take
three hours and have them run at three
in the morning so that when you come in
in the morning at eight or when you log
in your computer all that's been done
overnight and you've got your batch
scoring done and ready for you in the
morning
and then with blastula that we mentioned
earlier you can actually create and send
emails conditionally or on a schedule so
here we've got it scheduled for 9 36 a.m
central standard time i want this report
to run every day
and publish the output and send an email
we'll just for one quick second i'll
show you what this looks like actually
scheduled this report to run every hour
for the past few
hours so you can see i've got a couple
emails here it's been sending me
so we've got
an actual blastula email that has an
attachment of a pdf
a csv file and a powerpoint file all
this was generated with our markdown it
gave me an embedded ggplot an embedded
ggplot in an embedded table
and this was run with our studio connect
over and over and over uh with different
data and sending me these different
parameters
so this is the power of like all these
things you learn are amazingly powerful
in your local machine if you want to go
a step further and have like
authentication for these documents for
sharing within the enterprise or
scheduling or some of these other things
that are that are worth paying for
then you can look in rstudio connect and
do some of these amazing things
that being said you could also send
emails like this from gmail or from an
sntp server and you don't need our
studio connect but what rcu connect is
providing is the scheduling the
authentication the logging the history
some of those things that a lot of our
enterprise customers are concerned about
so that was a whirlwind tour we got it
done in exactly 60 minutes in this fun
experiment we did together so thank you
for tagging along with me listening to
me talking my uh my 200 worth per minute
voice thank you to allison hill for
defining that
um a bunch of different follow-up links
there's some articles that people in the
community have written about how to use
our markdown to be very powerful in your
enterprise so emily reuterer charlotte
gelfand have really great articles on
this i have one covering the same idea
of like a taxonomy of our markdown
there's two entire textbooks about our
markdown
the cookbook for different examples that
may answer some of the questions that
folks had in the chat that i didn't get
to
and then definitive guidebook which
shows all the possibilities of what you
can do with our markdown
we also have a few different webinars
that people in the community again have
showed like here's how we're using our
markdown or other things within our
enterprise or within our specific domain
so maybe you come from the insurance or
finance industry this report talks about
rethinking reporting with automation
nice video from the community there
using r to enhance clinical reporting
within the life sciences industry so
maybe you come from uh life sciences or
healthcare this has some clinical data
and clinical applications and one of my
favorites that's a bit more general is
avoid dashboard fatigue a lot of that is
talking about how to go beyond just
creating these kind of
dead dashboards and doing things like
scheduling doing things like creating
rich outputs
in different ways to engage with your
users
i know that rob or whoever is working
with me in the chat is also going to be
dropping
some links to some follow-up material
so he will be
dropping off a kind of summary of
everything that talks about some of the
packages that has links out to these
other things i talked about
and if you want to
look at the code i used and
you know riff off of it or adapt off it
or just play with it by yourself
you can go to my github at
github.com j thomas mock slash penguin
dash project
or bit dot l y
slash rmd marvel that's the short code
and i will drop that in the chat again
that will take you again to the same
page i'm on here with all the code oh
and i misspelled it apologies
bit.ly so let's try that again
see if we can get it rolling there we go
so my apologies
correct link
there
and you can have fun with it and again
i know that we covered a lot here i try
to be a bit more motivational with some
of these things in terms like here's the
things you can do and then giving you
examples to build off of i find the way
that i learn the best is from these
projects or doing project-based learning
where i can take something that i know
is working in a minimal way and expand
it to be useful for me and my job
uh do something in a different way that
is useful or a new way that i wasn't
able to do it before so go out have fun
with our markdown
you have all this amazing power
available for free that you can riff off
of and change uh so go out there use it
and have a good time
i'll stick around for a little bit
and try to answer some more questions as
they come in but that is the end of the
core presentation itself
and uh thank you for tagging along we
are doing this as an experiment so if
you could take some time and actually go
through and fill out the google form
that was just dropped in the chat uh
please do that
that will help us understand like what
other types of things y'all would like
to see in the future
where we can make improvements where i
kind of slipped up or where kind of
things could be better uh so thank you
all for attending thank you for your
time today and uh b
everything was fantastic i think so
thanks for thanks for your time i'll try
and answer a few of these different
questions
um oh also for anyone that's still here
this is howard this is the bonus howard
slide um it's almost the end of summer
here in texas not really but
uh this is my dog howard who loves
watermelon so
that's that's something to take home and
run with and have a good time with um
let's do some of these questions
i think i answered the one about
unmarked on render and flex dashboard
but again if you're using a static flex
dashboard you can just mark down render
it just as you would like
if you have a shiny component you will
then run the document as a shiny app
because you have to have that server
component
for parameters how can we get a list of
options with an api endpoint
that's really interesting i don't i
assume that you could pull in something
if you had like
a
an api and you were pulling in data with
say like the httr package then you could
pull that in
i'd have to think about using api as a
way to generate parameters and i don't
want to kind of speak off topic so
i'll try and do something in a follow-up
blog post for that and we'll release
that
is there a good way to
output a specified set of dashboard
views to a pdf
so you can use the webshot package that
is i didn't have enough time to talk
about that today but the webshot package
allows you to take screenshots of html
and then embed them somewhere else so
you can imagine that html is amazing
html is what i think you should be
creating because you can do so many
different things with it and make it
interactive
but sometimes people are like i need a
pdf or i don't have internet access i
need to have this or i want to print it
out
a couple different use cases
with a pdf you could actually do
web shop and print different html
views like a flex dashboard to a pdf
there is a blog post that we have in our
studio
our studio blog webshot
that covers that and we can find the
link
and
webshot two
so this package uh for printing html
this is a really powerful package for
doing all sorts of great things like
basically just taking
screenshots so here's a screenshot of
the
um
crayon and the r statistical project
home page uh from our 4.1 and the base r
pipe so pretty exciting stuff and just
being able to take images of that so you
can basically pass any html into that it
doesn't have to be a web page it could
be locally generated html as well
uh can you ask knitter to read several
dot our files absolutely so you could
either source or knit or read chunk from
multiple times
so you can imagine i have 10 different
dot r files you could read all those
into a parent or markdown document and
execute the code there
what are the best practices to produce
word documents from our markdown
let's go back here
so for word documents from our markdown
there's kind of two ways of doing it you
can do it with our markdown proper
there's also the what's called the
office first
that is a really powerful environment
for just working with office things you
can imagine powerpoint uh excel
and word like the kind of microsoft
office stack you can do a lot of those
different things with r and with our
markdown um there are certain
limitations or certain things you have
to work harder to do
but i think that you can still generate
you know useful things in our in from
our markdown into word to do those
when you think someone should use our
scripts over our markdown files um i try
and almost always use our markdown files
if i'm doing anything that is useful for
that so anything where i'm creating an
output or i'm trying to like capture my
train of thought
i know there are times where folks are
like well you know i have to send a dot
r file out to a high performance
computing cluster um that's fine like
you can use rmr and a dot r file and you
can still do useful uh workflows where
if i'm in a dot r file
i can create like a section label or
something so with command shift r
um i can do
you know cool label
and this will put a separator there
where i'm i'm doing labels or i can do
pound pound four dashes to also create a
section label
what this does is not only running
comments about what you're doing
but if you do want to bring these into
our markdown in the future now you can
use code chunk and read code chunk to
pull those in usefully into our markdown
file
that being said i find that working our
markdown especially with the visual
editor so the ability to
not only just you know see the raw plain
text or work with the plain text but
also have the rendered output in the
ability to like interject all sorts of
different things that can like
insert a level one heading like the
amazing things you can do with our
studio and our markdown are worth it
although dot our files can do the exact
same with uh r functions
this blastula run aside a docker
container on a virtual linux server does
it have limitations on the size of the
email attachment so
blastull like anything else could run
inside a docker environment um the way
that docker works or sorry the way that
blastula works is either you locally
generate an html file and send it via
smtp so i actually like render an actual
email
and then send it via gmail for example
or
i use rstudio connect to render it on a
server somewhere
rstudio connect doesn't require
kubernetes or doesn't require docker um
it just runs on a traditional uh bare
metal server like on premise or a
virtual cloud environment
so you don't need docker in that
workflow if you wanted to use docker
with flashlight you could but there's no
requirement to do that
limitations on the size of the email
i do think that the size of the email is
more limited by your
server client for sending emails or your
web client i know that for example i
think like gmail has a size limit on
images so if you try and send a gigabyte
of data via email gmail's just not gonna
let you do that that's not a blastula
thing that's just a gmail thing
um
but
you can attach basically anything you
can create an r you can attach to an
email so pdfs excel files csvs rds files
images entire reports or html files
those can all be attached
things that are in line in blastula and
i think we actually have
a control document i can show this we're
way over but we're just going to have
fun with that let's look at a blastula
email
that's not the one i wanted uh
penguin emailer
there we go
so when i actually render the email this
is a preview that you can run with the
package this is not been sent but it
shows you what the email would look like
as a preview
so this is an embedded ggplot it's
literally inline so in your actual email
that you send to someone it'll have this
text and it will have this image
um however some clients are very
aggressive with stripping html so if you
tried to say do a table with gt
that might
not
render exactly as you want not because
gt's do anything wrong but just because
your email client can't parse html that
you know complexity so what you can do
instead is attach an image uh directly
and that will typically work in any of
the clients
the one addendum there though
is that attaching uh tables as images
does remove all the metadata of a table
and essentially makes it a an image like
a graphic
so it might be better to attach a report
and just say like here are some quick
summaries there um but for a lot of
email clients you can still embed tables
within them all right i think that's
actually all of it um we still have
around 400 people here so thank you for
spending some time with me and going a
bit over um have a wonderful weekend be
safe um you know enjoy our markdown have
a good time and we will see you next
time
tom logging off
closing down a lot of things and
have a good one